bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mon sur rt france on imagine votre
colère aujourd'hui tout à fait
scandaleux au regard de la crise qu vide
où tout le monde a dû se serrer la
ceinture les les salaires ont été gelés
il ya eu des milliers d'emplois des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois supprimés
à travers le monde
et au passage le le patron se sert en
revoyant à la baisse ses ambitions en
terme de deux cours de bourse il de 47
millions pour réduire la valeur dans
l'entreprise et pour détruire des
emplois
comment la direction justifie t'elle ce
bonus à priori c'était pour garder le
directeur qui a renégocié son contrat
cet été
il devait toucher 47 millions si
l'action passée de 12 à 19 dollars
maintenant le seuil n'ait pu dîner de
l'armée de 10 $ qui est assurée d'adp
obtenir car ça fait trente jours que
l'action et au delà des 10 dollars et
devait pas chez touché 230 millions à
condition que l'action pas au delà des
31 dollar soit la valeur avant
l'acquisition d'alstom mais au contraire
l'action du dirigeant détruit de la
valeur détruit de la valeur sondés sur
des marchés qui ont de l'avenir le
marché de l'énergie le nucléaire le
renouvelable même de gaza a beaucoup
d'avenir et il a vendu des pépites
il réduit les budgets d'investissement
ils délocalisent
il détruit de la valeur de jour après
jour general electric vaut beaucoup
moins maintenant qu'il ya deux ans et
malgré ça il est récompensé ce qui est
totalement scandaleux
au regard de du plan d'économies général
dans le monde entier vous pensez que la
pression les critiques qui se
multiplient depuis hier peuvent empêcher
le versement d'au moins une partie de
cette prime de rappel 47 millions $ un
prime qui a un look était promise au pdg
de general electric
je pense que l'état doit intervenir
général tig a expliqué à l'état qu'il
n'était pas possible d'investir dans le
projet industriel dans les filles
r en france qui n'avait pas les moyens
de le faire on voit que maintenant il
est capable de verser 2 47 millions de
dollars à son patron c'est justement la
somme nécessaire pour créer de la valeur
pour développer l'activité en france la
croix il s'est engagé
l'état doit intervenir je pense qu'on ne
peut plus accepter en france que des
fleurons industriels soient vendus à des
mercenaires qui font comment dire qu'ils
mettent en comment dire qu'ils
s'enrichissent sur le dos des salariés
mais également des actionnaires imaginez
un actionnaire qui pensaient que
l'action poule et monte à 31 dollars et
maintenant lui annonce que le patron
touchera le pactole si l'action dépasse
les 17 dollars
donc on est face à une caste de deux
dirigeants qui font passer leurs
intérêts avant celui de leur entreprise
on est plus sur les dirigeants
industriels à long terme qui créent de
la valeur general electric être soit des
filières d'avenir l'énergie s'il ya
d'avenir mais ne crée plus de valeur
arrête les investissements délocalise
dans les pays à bas coûts une fois
qu'ils auront tous d colisée en inde
gens parce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire de
plus pour d'inventer des preuves des
profits futurs
cette situation est inacceptable
monsieur qu'elle s'enrichit l autre
filière industrielle française est en
train d'être exterminés à belfort ou
ailleurs c'est entre 25 et 40% des
effectifs qui ont déjà été supprimés ce
sont des territoires qui vivent
exclusivement des six fédéraliste reyel
qui sont en train de disparaître et ça
sous les yeux du gouvernement
vous avez organisé hier une conférence
de presse au cours de laquelle vous avez
estimé qu'il était à grand temps que la
france remette la main sur la branche
énergie d'alstom racheté par general
electric
en quoi selon vous la situation serait
telle vraiment différente aujourd'hui
si la france était aux manettes tout
d'abord la première chose qu'a fait
général explique s'est délocalisé les
centres de décision donc en 2015
les directs les dirigeants étaient en
france il était en charge la stratégie
française ils avaient leur avenir en
main
maintenant tous les dirigeants tous les
business aussi bien les turbines à gaz
où il ya un seul dirigeant en france qui
a un contrat suisse
a pas d'équipé pas de budget aux siens
dans le nucléaire on a un seul
dirigeante dont le poste est supprimé
dans les renouvelables on aille bien
monsieur pécresse mais 20% de son staff
et uniquement en france en comptant le
chauffeur l'assistant et c'est donc déjà
il ya ya plus de décisions ce qu'on sait
plus une boîte française l'ex alstom
deuxièmement ils ont délocalisé les
brevets ils ont délocalisé les profits
en suisse avec des vastes plans
d'évasion fiscale maintenant il
déconnait délocaliser les emplois
donc si génétique avait respecté ses
engagements et encore une fois la corde
2014 prévoyait que ces ondes éditions
restent en france et l'état un moyen de
pression sur general electric
regardez leur impact les choses seraient
différentes car au moins nous aurions
des dirigeants en france à qui discutait
avec qui on pourrait comprendre et
échanger là la stratégie pour l'instant
en france nous avons que des guignols
qui n'ont aucune marge de manoeuvre
tout est décidé outre atlantique les
l'industrie française ne peut grandir
que si les conditions sont en france
c'est vraiment l'idée de l'accord qui a
été signé pour lequel l'état doit doit
le faire respecter
et si le jean ne respecte pas il faut
sanctionner et remettre la main sur
cette filière à du fret d'avenir avant
qu'il ne reste plus rien d'un mot assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien vous
comptez mener des actions pour
manifester votre mécontentement comment
est ce que vous espérez vous faire
entendre de la direction de general
electric
tout d'abord les négociations salaires
annuels vont débuter ce vendredi
je ne pense pas que les salariés vont
accepter cette situation
je pense qu'il ya des choses qui vont
pouvoir se faire des mobilisations qui
sont possibles au regard de cette
situation relativement scandaleuse
deuxièmement nous comptons
on continue à travailler sur l'accord de
2014 et si l'état ne bouge pas notre
plainte est prête et une mise en demeure
va d'être renvoyé rapidement et le
troisième a sauvé c'est l'aspect fiscal
general electric délocalisent
massivement hors de france des activités
qui valent beaucoup d'argent fiscalement
en france délocaliser ce n'est pas
gratuit
general electric ne compte pas passer à
la caisse et c'est un argument qui peut
être utilisé pour faire changer les
choses et remettre la main sur la
filière industrielle l'ex entité alstom
merci beaucoup d'avoir agi sur notre
antenne philippe petitcolin représentant
cfe cgc de l'entité turbines à gaz
française de general electric